c'est sur la base militaire américaine
de Rammstein en Allemagne que s'est
déroulée la nouvelle rencontre de tous
les alliés de l'Ukraine une 15e réunion
de coordination de l'aide militaire en
présence du nouveau ministre ukrainien
de la Défense le secrétaire américain à
la Défense l'oeil d'Austin a indiqué que
la contre-offensive ukrainienne
progressée régulièrement face aux troupe
russe et qu'elle sera bientôt soutenue
par l'arrivée sur le terrain des chars
promis par Washington
nous devons continuer à faire des
efforts importants pour fournir à
l'Ukraine les systèmes de défense
aérienne dont elle a besoin je suis
heureux d'annoncer que les chars M1
Abrams sur lesquels les États-Unis
s'étaient engagés auparavant entre rond
bientôt en Ukraine
en janvier Washington s'était engagé à
fournir 31 Abrahams au total des chars
lourds qui rejoindront les challengers 2
livré par Londres et les Léopards 2 de
fabrication allemande les responsables
ukrainiens ont une nouvelle fois insisté
sur l'urgence d'obtenir plus de moyens
pour faire face aux troupes R et
contrôler l'espace aérien et pour
maintenir la pression dans leur contres
offensive qui est a indiqué avoir repris
7 km² de territoires au cours de la
semaine écoulée après la libération de
plusieurs villages près de la ville
dévastée de barmouth sur le front-est
engagé depuis début juin dans une
difficile contre-offensive face aux
lignes fortifiées russes les forces
ukrainiennes tentent d'accentuer la
pression ces dernières semaines avant
l'arrivée de l'hiver les bombardements
Russes et les attaques de drone se
poursuivent quotidiennement sur
l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien dont
la nuit de lundi à mardi Nicolas IV a
été visé par des drones mardi matin
c'est le vive qui en a été la